hi my name's Scott Williamson and I'm
the CEO of the mega center here in
reading I'm Julie soulfood one of the
family support workers here at mega
center just wanted to say thank you
we're here in volunteers week and it's a
great opportunity to celebrate all the
fantastic work that volunteers do across
our community I've been struck over the
last few months about the amazing work
that volunteers have done as they've
stepped forward to support the
vulnerable the isolated the scared
residents in our community as we've had
the corona virus pandemic it's been
amazing to see the work that's been done
we've had such great feedback from
residents who have really valued the
work that's been done but also from the
volunteers themselves who have felt
really wonderful to be part of a bigger
team somebody said that sometimes it's
just a friendly voice at the end of the
phone that could make all the difference
being a volunteer can help you
individually as well it can alleviate
stress anger anxiety give you some
fantastic skills to take forward to put
on your CV if you're looking for paid
work so we just want to say again just
thank you so so much because by your
volunteering over these last few months
you have made a big big difference in
our community and when you just want to
say thank you but we want to say
continue to volunteer it's a great thing
to do because volunteering helps us as
people but also helps our community and
helps change the world so this week we
just was a thank you on behalf of myself
and Julie and the other partners thank
you so so much we could have done it
without you we thank you for your
volunteering and goodbye
you